Traduttore: Peggy Berthier
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Entro ed esco dal carcere
da una decina di anni
e i miei reati non sono
tentativi di rapina,
ma sono reiterati tentativi di fare
del teatro, dell'educazione, della terapia
e qualche cosa che assomiglia all'arte.
La prima volta che sono entrata in carcere
era il 2008, me la ricordo perfettamente,
perché per la prima volta ho visto
dei detenuti, dei criminali dal vero,
ed erano lì davanti a me
e io che mi chiedevo:
“Chissà se hanno spacciato o rubato,
non avranno mica ammazzato qualcuno”,
perché mi sembrava veramente impossibile,
erano delle persone assolutamente
normali davanti a me,
e dei ragazzi, degli uomini, alcuni
erano anche decisamente carini.
Da allora non ho più smesso,
e se mi chiedete il perché
è perché credo che
in nessun posto come in galera
il mio agire abbia portato
della trasformazione.
Io vengo dal teatro,
dove tutto è trasformazione,
storia e personaggi, materiali,
eppure in nessun posto come in carcere
ho potuto assaporare
il potere trasformativo del teatro
e non sugli oggetti o sulle storie,
ma direttamente e incisivamente
nel nucleo delle persone, che per un po'
di tempo giocano a fare gli attori.
E allora ho deciso di scommetterci
su questa trasformazione
ed è questa l'idea che secondo me
ha senso raccontarvi oggi:
di come abbia un'utilità e un senso
portare della trasformazione in carcere,
attraverso gli strumenti
del teatro e della drammaterapia.
Drammaterapia, che di drammatico
ha soltanto il nome,
perché in realtà è una terapia
a mediazione artistica
che utilizza gli strumenti
appunto del teatro e del dramma
per lavorare sulla prevenzione,
sulla cura, sull'educazione
e sulla rieducazione.
Se voi ci pensate, noi come società civile
diamo al carcere una missione,
che è una missione trasformativa,
come se fosse il cappello di un mago,
un cilindro in cui mettiamo
dentro un fazzoletto
et voilà, tiriamo fuori un coniglio.
Noi chiediamo al carcere di contenere
delle persone, fare una qualche magia
e restituirci delle persone trasformate
in persone oneste, per bene.
Avevamo messo dentro
ovviamente dei delinquenti.
Questa magia non funziona sempre,
purtroppo non funziona neanche spesso,
visto i dati altissimi delle recidive.
È una missione trasformativa quella che
noi diamo in un istituto penitenziario,
e allora mi sono chiesta:
quali sono gli strumenti del dramma
e del teatro che possono essere utili
e in qualche modo concorrere a portare
questo cambiamento, questa trasformazione,
che noi legittimamente come società civile
ci aspettiamo che lì dentro avvenga,
quindi, un passaggio da un delinquente
a una persona per bene.
Secondo me ci sono molti degli strumenti
del teatro, della pratica teatrale,
che possono essere utili
per operarlo questo cambiamento.
Ve ne racconto alcuni che però
secondo me sono i più significativi.
Innanzitutto: a far teatro si fa fatica,
si fa una grandissima fatica.
Io immagino che pochi di voi
sappiano tutto il lavoro
che c'è dietro due ore di spettacolo.
Lavoro anche fisico proprio
in termini di sudore da parte degli attori
che sono sul palcoscenico.
Ecco, molti degli attori detenuti,
con cui lavoro io,
con cui lavoriamo noi in carcere,
sono delle persone che nella loro vita
non hanno fatto fatica un giorno solo,
perché in carcere
ci si va per disperazione,
anche per mancanza di mezzi
culturali e materiali,
ma ci si va anche per amore
di una vita comoda.
Conosco persone che non si sono
mai alzate alle 6:00 del mattino
per andare a lavorare alle 7:00,
perché i soldi a fine mese entrano
per dei canali più facili e più comodi.
Quando si fa teatro
tutto questo non funziona.
Se devi fare uno spettacolo,
o vieni alle prove, o fai le prove,
o studi la memoria, o provi 120.000 volte
quel singolo gesto, quella battuta,
quella partitura di movimenti, o
semplicemente uno spettacolo non si crea.
Se non vieni alle prove,
non puoi pensare di mandare
uno scugnizzo che faccia le prove
e tu ti presenti alla fine la sera
del debutto a prendere gli applausi,
perché non funziona così.
Ed è esattamente questo quello che
noi stiamo insegnando a questi detenuti
nel fare teatro:
che tanto lavori, tanto ottieni.
Stiamo insegnando la fatica per ottenere
un risultato che non è scontato,
ma è un risultato che deve
essere sudato e guadagnato,
e stiamo insegnando una disciplina.
E io credo che, all'interno
del cappello del mago,
sia bene che una disciplina in qualche
momento la si apprenda, si possa imparare.
Un altro degli strumenti che da il teatro
è quello del poter lavorare
sulla collaborazione,
che è diverso
dell'associazione a delinquere:
sia l'associazione a delinquere
che il lavoro di gruppo in altri ambiti
hanno alcuni principi condivisi,
ma diversi sono
sicuramente i metodi e gli scopi,
perché il teatro per antonomasia
è non a scopo di lucro,
non è a scopo di lucro
neanche per chi lo fa di mestiere,
quindi figuriamoci per tutti
gli altri, insomma.
In teatro, se non ci sei,
se non fai quello che devi fare
rischi di compromettere
lo spettacolo di tutti.
In carcere potrebbero fartela pagare,
ma nel fartela pagare
non ci guadagna nessuno.
Se il tuo compagno dietro le quinte
non si ricorda la battuta,
non sa quando deve entrare,
ecco, quello è un problema tuo,
perché non ne va del suo spettacolo, ne va
del tuo spettacolo, del vostro spettacolo.
C'è soltanto il nostro, in quel momento.
E lui il suo errore, la sua distrazione,
sono una cosa che deve riguardare te
e a cui tu devi porre rimedio.
Perché non puoi scappare,
salvare la tua pelle:
in quel momento non c'è la tua pelle,
c'è soltanto la nostra pelle.
Questo credo che sia il germe del senso
civico, di una responsabilità civile,
che manca o che è mancata a chi delinque,
e noi stiamo provando a fare questo:
ad insegnare a queste persone,
attraverso il teatro,
a prendersi cura degli altri, delle cose
degli altri come se fossero mie,
perché sono mie
in quel momento, sono nostre,
perché siamo una compagnia teatrale
e nel grande siamo una polis, una società.
E poi c'è un altro tema che a me
sta particolarmente a cuore:
il teatro permette di riabilitare
la propria immagine di sé.
Si fa tantissimo parlare
in ambito pedagogico ed educativo
di quanto sia importante fornire
ai bambini nella fase della crescita
delle immagini positive di se stessi
e quindi migliorare l'autostima.
Voi immaginate che il teatro, il carcere
- anche il teatro - è pieno di bambini,
che hanno dei corpi muscolosi, palestrati,
tatuati, brutti e cattivi a volte,
ma che dentro conservano
uno spirito infantile
che tante volte è stato traumatizzato,
perché in carcere ci si va
per amore della suddetta vita comoda,
ma in carcere c'è anche chi ci finisce
perché non ha nessuna possibilità
di un altro destino.
C'è chi lì dentro non ha vissuto altro
se non violenza, se non delinquenza.
C'è chi ha sempre vissuto
ai margini della legalità, del lecito.
Chi nella vita ha imparato
solo a cavarsela da solo
a dare, prendere botte,
e soprattutto c'è chi
non si è mai sentito dire:
“Bravo! Complimenti! Va’ che cosa
bella che hai fatto! Sei stato bravo!”
Questa è la mia domanda fondamentale:
"Come pensiamo di trasformare,
di chiedere un cambiamento
a delle persone che di se stesse sanno
soltanto di essere dei buoni a nulla,
dei poco di buono,
dei delinquenti, dei cattivi?"
"Come facciamo a chiedergli
di mantenersi nel giusto,
se questa persona di se stessa
sa soltanto di essere un delinquente
perché nessuno gli ha mai detto,
quando era grande così,
che c'era una possibilità diversa?"
"Come possiamo chiedere a qualcuno
di mantenersi nel giusto,
se lui questo giusto
semplicemente non lo conosce?"
Il teatro permette
a molti di questi detenuti
di percepirsi per la prima volta
in un'altra maniera,
di prendere un applauso,
di prendere un complimento.
Voi provate ad immaginarvi
di mettervi davanti allo specchio
e non poter elencare
una cosa buona, di valore,
che avete fatto nella vostra vita.
Che motivazione avreste
di mantenervi nella giustizia?
Un po' di mesi fa abbiamo portato
in carcere a Busto Arsizio
una compagnia di 10 detenuti,
e c'erano più di 500 persone a vederci,
forse volevano vedere
che faccia avevano questi brutti ceffi.
Hanno scoperto che sono
delle persone normali,
alcuni anche dei buoni attori.
E quando si è aperto il sipario
si è sentita levare dalla platea
la voce di una bambina che chiamava papà.
Questa bambina aveva visto suo papà Willy
sul palcoscenico, che usciva per recitare.
Questa bimba il suo papà Willy
lo vede da tre anni soltanto un'ora
la settimana, nella sala dei colloqui,
che è una sala abbellita,
ma è comunque la sala di una galera,
ci sono altre persone.
E il suo papà lo sente per 10-15 minuti
la settimana, per telefono.
Voi pensate quanto bene
ha fatto a questa bambina
vedere quella sera il suo papà Willy,
lì bello sul palcoscenico,
bravo, applaudito da tutti,
che sapeva recitare, che faceva ridere.
Per quella bambina, suo papà quella sera
era tornato ad essere il supereroe
che ogni papà dovrebbe
essere per una figlia.
E provate a pensare
quanto bene ha fatto a questo papà potersi
far vedere così dalla propria famiglia.
Una famiglia che ha deluso, che è lontana
e di cui non può prendersi cura,
una famiglia verso la quale
sicuramente si sente in colpa.
Questo significa cambiare
la propria immagine di sé.
Questo significa permettere
di percepirsi in un modo diverso,
in un modo che è buono, costruttivo,
socialmente accettabile ed accettato,
e questo per un detenuto,
che presto diventerà - presto o tardi -
diventerà un ex detenuto,
è importante poterlo fare.
Devono potersi immaginare
con una potenzialità di buono interno,
per poter aderire a quel cambiamento,
e allo stesso modo è importante
che la società possa immaginare
una potenzialità positiva
in quelle persone.
Perché altrimenti
come facciamo a reinglobarli,
come possiamo poi
reimpiegarli costruttivamente?
Questo è quello che stiamo tentando
di fare all'interno del carcere di Busto,
da una decina d’anni
con questa nostra avventura teatrale,
e abbiamo fatto un'associazione di recente
per riuscire a farlo un po' meglio.
Si chiama “L'oblò”,
perché noi abbiamo un'idea di carcere
che è come una sorta di grande nave,
che porta delle persone da una libertà
a un'altra libertà, una prossima libertà.
Noi vogliamo esserci in questo percorso,
perché questo tragitto
sia il più significativo possibile
e per poter fare in modo
che l'arrivo alla prossima libertà
sia un po' migliore di quello precedente.
Quello che stiamo facendo
attraverso gli strumenti del teatro
e della drammaterapia, è rieducazione.
Rieducare, che significa
riportare ad un ambito di dignità
le persone che la dignità l'hanno persa,
stanno giustamente pagando
per quanto fatto;
ma finché questa dignità non viene
in qualche maniera ripristinata,
a mio avviso non è possibile
in nessun modo un reale cambiamento.
Nelle parole del mio grande amico
Pino, detenuto di lunga data,
che ha acquistato un tot di saggezza:
“Rieducare è ridare dignità”.
Nelle mie parole, rieducare
è restituire al bello,
perché io sono anche quello
che gli altri vedono di me
e se per una sera una platea intera invece
di vedere il disgraziato, il delinquente,
di me, vede un attore bravo, capace,
che sa far ridere, che sa far piangere,
che sa far emozionare, può essere
che anch'io scelga di aderire
a quello che per una sera
gli altri hanno visto,
a quell'immagine buona di me
che gli altri hanno visto
e può essere che io scelga di cambiare
e di tornare a crederci: può essere.
(Applausi)
(Grazie)